[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance first they came for the
undocumented Americans and I did not
speak out because I was not you knew
that original speech from Pastor Martin
niemöller from the late 1940s and you
knew you heard the first few letters of
the first word of the confession of
eternal guilt and regret as they began
to echo over the last long weekend in
Southern California in Atlanta in Austin
in other places and you knew that ice
immigrations and Customs Enforcement may
have said there was nothing unusual
about the roundups and yet you also knew
that the Barbarian in chief could not
resist boasting about the truth and
making Liars in the process out of his
gangs of deportation stormtroopers and
you knew that he would say something
like the crackdown on illegal criminals
is merely the keeping of my campaign
promise
gang members drug dealers and others are
being removed others like the mother of
two Americans teenagers she's been
living here since she was 14 she checked
in annually for eight years with her
immigration officer just as they told
her to each time receiving work
authorization until last week when she
checked in with them and they seized her
and drove her to Mexico gang member
drug dealer know when she was originally
arrested she was part of the cleaning
crew at an Arizona water park her name
is Guadalupe garcia de reyes and donald
trump is proud of having removed the
danger she represented to this country
because Donald Trump is a cowardly
hateful bully who was elected on a
promise to scapegoat people with dark
skin because from disease or abuse or as
Clarence Darrow said of the murderers
Leopold and Loeb because somewhere in
the infinite processes that go to the
making up of the boy or the man
something slipped for whatever reason
Donald Trump thinks expelling people who
will uncomplainingly do the jobs that
people who were born here often do not
want to do is somehow to his credit and
is somehow to this nation's benefit when
in fact the whole history of this
country is predicated on people who
came here like Fredrick Trump and Mike
Fredrick Olbermann who uncomplainingly
did the jobs that people who had been
born here would not do in the hopes that
their sons or grandson or great-great
grand sons might flourish in this nation
of bounty and goodness instead we have
this Trump adviser Stephen Miller the
one with the dead eyes shifting side to
side as if the eyes themselves were
rebelling against his racism and
deception insisting on television that
quote before a job is given to a foreign
national that job is offered first to an
American worker because they're going to
be overwhelmed at that Arizona water
park with American workers who want the
job for minimum wage of cleaning the
[ __ ] from the toilet bowls and again on
behalf of Friedrich Crump and Friedrich
Oberman I apologize to Guadalupe Garcia
de Reyes and her family and the world
and I also have to apologize to Trump's
supporters so filled with misdirected
rage about the failures in their own
lives that they have never considered
what happens to them if all the people
who do all those jobs suddenly disappear
step back from me molars lament for a
moment and table the hatred and the
racism and the scapegoating and the
terror by night and remember Trump
supporters who is now expected to do
guadalupe garcia de Rios's job at that
water park or somebody else's job in the
kitchen or yet another job in the crop
fields on the farms you are or your son
or the ex factory worker who isn't
getting his factory job back no matter
what Trump promised him because there's
nobody anywhere who will buy the product
the factory produces not at those prices
take the emotion out of it
take the rightness and the wrongness out
of this unamerican spectacle this Salem
witch trial of 2017 and ask yourself
what happens to the food on your table
when the people who harvest it aren't
here anymore because you decided they
didn't belong here anymore that food
rots in the field see the thing is this
throw the illegals purge has been done
here before in America recently and the
results were disastrous in 2011 the
state of Georgia passed a bill
called HB 87 proud state representative
from Peachtree City Matt Ramsey a
co-author said at the time the bill
would give the police the right to
demand immigration documents from
anybody detained for any reason it would
also he said punish those who hired or
harbored undocumented Americans our goal
is said representative Ramsey to
eliminate incentives for illegal aliens
to cross into our state and how well it
all worked an estimated 425 thousand
undocumented Americans were employed in
Georgia in 2010 but by the harvest time
of 2011 at least 40 percent of the
workers Georgia farmers needed were gone
the Georgia born unemployed whose jobs
those quote illegals unquote had taken
from them they not only wanted no part
of the back-breaking labor those of you
who tried it were evidently not as good
at it 40% of the men and women who
actually knew how to work the farms of
Georgia and how to survive on minimal
incomes suddenly vanished and as
representative Matt Ramsey and the
others cheered an estimated 140 million
dollars worth of Georgia produce rotted
in the fields by 2012 as farmers planted
last due to the sudden labor scarcity in
Georgia the state was forced to find new
farm workers prisoners they bust in
prisoners to work the farms Georgia's
agricultural economy still has not fully
recovered oh and he's now former
representative Matt Ramsey so if you are
so lacking in human soul that what this
madman bigoted Trump has just begun to
roll out doesn't sear your flesh when
you embrace it
forget the ethics for a while and think
instead of what it will do to your
wallet when the ticket to the water park
doubles in price because guadalupe is
not there to clean it for you and the
price of the meal at the fancy
restaurant or the fast food shack
triples because your cousin isn't there
to cook it for you and the price of the
food you buy at the supermarket
quadruples because none of them are
there to pick it for you
you don't have to have the heart of
pasture niemoller to have the regret of
pastor nemo or then
in fact you don't have to have a heart
at all just a wallet first they came for
the undocumented Americans and I did not
speak out because I was not undocumented
and I didn't realize that without them
it would cost too much for me to feed my
own family resist peace